obviously a lot of conversation about
you what's going to happen what are you
going to do every single article says he
is expected to decline his player option
where are you at with that are you
declining that option oh you're retiring
we'll probably decline that and do the
free agency thing my my first free
agency was I was restricted and it was
it was ass I kind of actually cried a
little bit it took like three weeks to
get it done I'm like damn like do people
want me in the league like I don't think
this free agency would go that way I
love New York I love the team I love the
the coaches that at the front office
that we have got young guys draft picks
do all the you know all those sort of
things so you know obviously that would
be an ideal place for me to just you
know resign there and do that everything
is perfect on the court off the court
you know with family being close to home
doing all those kind of things so you
know fingers crossed that you know for
you know what breeds he starts I'll say
a deal get done you know in the first
day or two I would love for that to be
home